when you tear it open you can watch the
cheese mousse out o my mouth is watering
already
my name is curly and this is my Abuelita
Gladys demo hacer ahora
sweet class and we're gonna make boots
from El Salvador
since we're forever pupusas are like a
small little tortillas made of masa
they're like to go food like you
literally you can pick it up and run
with it you can eat it anywhere if
you're in your car if you're at work if
you're in church if you're hanging out
of your friend's house if you're on the
couch if you're in a dining area we do
eat it with the condiment called go to
evoke the good feel for me is so
important because it just adds a whole
nother flavor like it's the way that I
would describe it and I might get some
side for it it's kind of similar to like
a sauerkraut like it just adds that
little kick my memories of who says have
always been with my Abuelita
when we have parties or gatherings with
Salvadoran folk there's usually somebody
who is Luciano somebody who's like
making pupusas for the whole family
when do casinos him premiere cuento de
mi mamá por que Viva Marcia Paquita
pupusas not tortilla para la gente de
donde and rhetorical via TV ad not avid
I comment
they've been very topical now I leave a
compress call me that not a coma my
favorite part about my wig now is making
the pupusas is the fact that people
place their orders with her and she
always forgets what you order she's like
yes yes anything you need and then just
serves you whatever she's making yes
look at that that looks delicious huh
more we call muy bien but bosses are
shared by so many cultures sometimes
there's a little bit of a squabble over
who did it whether Honduran sitter or
Salvadorans in it but at the end of the
day we're all the same people anyways so
I'm like just eat up a poster and enjoy
so whatever has the best people says oh
yeah my grandma is actually one of my
best friends in the whole wide world
like I I always get emotional when I
talk about it but like as a young gay
kid she was always there for me and so
when we spend time together
I sometimes understand that it might be
limited and so being able to cook
together and
learn traditions as she went from her
mother and then for me to be able to
carry them on it kind of there's things
that will stay with me for forever
so for me means a lot to hear be able to
cook my grandma you always made me cry
always cry when I'm with you but
boosters can actually be filled with a
lot of different things you can put
cheese in it but black is so the boys
when I teach are on frijoles
loroco lo que tu Cara they've been they
look exactly depending on what the
people like whatever you're wanting some
people make it differently I want to try
yours if you make your soggy
I wanna try yours if you make your
crispy I'm gonna do yours like that's
the beauty even if you make an ugly
boo-boos that doesn't matter they all
taste delicious I've never met a pupusas
I didn't like bueno si Mira como Yamaha
termina rocky ketamine amo say cocinar
esto en emocionado Pro Barlowe's I'm
excited are you excited to eat on oh
yeah I'm so excited we're gonna propose
four days now oh yeah Mira mmm saying
I'm a coma hello Luis our office oh yes
[Music]
hey guys do you know what this panic
Heritage Month nobody for more Latino
content subscribe here